♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELL, FOR MANY
YEARS, ED BUCK HAS BEEN A
BIG-TIME FUND-RAISER FOR
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
THERE HE IS WITH
HILLARY CLINTON.
SHE PROBABLY MET HIM BETWEEN
VISITS WITH JEFFREY EPSTEIN AND
HARVEY WEINSTEIN.
IT TURNS OUT THAT WHEN HE WASN'T
DONATING TO THE DEMOCRATS, HE
LIKED.
TWO SEPARATE MEN HAVE DIED
INSIDE BUCK'S WEST HOLLYWOOD
HOME.
HERE'S THE AMAZING PART.
AUTHORITIES LOOKED AT THAT AND
SHRUGGED.
HE FACED NO CHARGES.
HE APPARENTLY HAS GONE TOO FAR.
A THIRD MAN INSIDE ED BUCK'S
HOME.
EVERYONE KNEW THAT HE WAS
INJECTING YOUNG PEOPLE WITH
NARCOTICS AND NO ONE DID
ANYTHING.
THE THIRD OH DO YOU GOD SURVIVED
EVERYONE KNEW WHAT HE WAS DOING.
HE WAS INJECTING THEM WITH
DEADLY AMOUNTS OF
METHAMPHETAMINES.
THEY FINALLY CHARGED HIM WITH
EVERYONE KNEW HE WAS DOING FOR